so Donald Trump nixed the Iran deal
which he said he'd do all along I am
announcing today that the United States
will withdraw from the Iran nuclear deal
we will be instituting the highest level
of economic sanction any nation that
helps Iran in its quest for nuclear
weapons could also be strongly
sanctioned by the United States America
will not be held hostage to nuclear
blackmail today's action sends a
critical message the United States no
longer makes empty threats when I make
promises I keep them now before that
apparently John Kerry spoke to Iranian
leaders about saving the deal I don't
blame the guy Kerry's legacy is
unraveling faster than a mummy on a
merry-go-round his legacy is right up
there with new coke and the whole point
of the Iran deal was legacy it wasn't
security before this boneheaded deal
Iran was on the ropes the economy was
headed into North Korean territory and
the place was about as stable as Jim
Carrey on a skateboard then we threw
them a lifeline so the left could have
something to write about in their
history books stupid we went to
negotiate with a bunch of apocalyptic
theocrats
and we sent this guy what's the matter
Katy Perry was booked one question did
James Taylor strum a little mood music
well the mullahs screwed us so now for
Kerry there ran deals like a crappy
Shack on the vital plot of land and the
new guy Trump tore it down so does this
mean war no if you think the current
present president harbors a grudge
against Iran you'd be wrong he seems
willing to talk to just about anyone the
only thing he hates his dumb deals
he'd rather start clean this is his
version of a reset a reset with leverage
listen
Iran's leaders will naturally say that
they refuse to negotiate a new deal they
refuse and that's fine I'd probably say
the same thing if I was in their
position but the fact is they are going
to want to make
new and lasting deal one that benefits
all of Iran and the Iranian people when
they do I am ready willing and able
great things can happen for Iran and
great things can happen for the peace
and stability that we all want in the
Middle East so that's nice so for those
of you in a panic remember you felt that
way about North Korea to Trump's pattern
seems to do that to people as he deals
with the worst on the planet as he
scratches off Isis in North Korea Iran
seems next it's a skill set that history
will be kinder to than to John Kerry all
right Dana on a scale of one being super
awesome to ten which is super super
super super super super super super
super awesome where would you put this
speech it was right up there all right
no you have to say the whole thing
super super yes awesome
here's the other thing did President
Trump keep his promise but remember we
are 18 months into his presidency yeah
he gave the people that wanted to keep
this this deal intact who gave them a
chance to persuade them he was not
persuaded not by people here in America
or not by the visitors from Europe that
came to visit and he decided he's not he
wasn't just gonna take a little piece
out of it so that we're actually pulling
out of the entire thing and he made his
case whether he's persuasive enough
across the board I don't know but it
doesn't actually matter the person who
wasn't persuasive enough initially was
President Obama because he did not
decide to have the Senate vote on it as
a treaty that meant that he did it by
executive action if you look at the
things that President Obama did under
executive action President Trump has
been able to dismantle those quite
easily an exception is Obamacare
Obamacare was passed by the Congress and
it was upheld by the Supreme Court that
has been actually something that has
been kind of chip away at it but it
still exists so president Trump took
decisive action but it was really not
that I don't think it's that
unprecedented given that it was not a
treaty it was a decision President Obama
made and there might be consequences
from it but I think that I think it was
a good
decision all right Jesse welcome back
thank you much better than kill me
yo Trump does this all the time he
clearly need to say yes I just had to do
it just because you know yes you know
this is this what Trump always says
there's chaos and confusion but that's
his starting point it's like if you're
gonna start a deal it's gotta be you you
shouldn't be the predictable one in this
deal right sometimes tearing up a bad
deal is makes you safer my mother has
already texted me she said this I prayed
this morning that Trump doesn't
withdraws from the Iran deal if you
choose to support and applaud that
decision I'm feeling that it is probably
likely that I will need to take a break
you of course know that I love you so
mom I will say this now that the
Obamacare mandate is gone and the Iran
nuke deal is gone
probably the presidential library might
lose a wing because this legacy now has
shrunk pretty quickly I can't I can't
think of a very funny pun as Greg would
like a mummy pawn but it's shrinking and
it's shrinking fast I would say this you
were exactly right in the monologue they
had the sanctions in place and had max
leverage and were squeezing them hard
and instead of ratcheting that up they
caved and gave him a sweetheart deal
they gave him billions of dollars in
cash which they used on missiles and
terrorism they were violating the deal
they exceeded the heavy-water capacity
the inspections were a joke they
actually let them self inspect could you
imagine that the Iranians self
inspecting they were banning inspectors
from their military sites satellite
images shows at the military site inside
a bunker in a mountain that's being
moved around they're opening up doors
and they're doing some refurbishing
there so that's very suspicious you know
the Israeli spies smuggled all those
documents out of Iran they say the guy's
lie just to facilitate the deal in the
first place so the entire thing was bad
they let the ballistic missiles stay
they you know did really nothing to make
sure the deal was enforced the worst
part about it was Ben Rhodes the
national security adviser bragged about
how he sold these lies through the fake
news media about how good of a deal it
was because if you actually put the deal
to a Senate vote like a treaty would go
no one would have voted for it because
it was so ridiculous they allowed them
to spin centrifuges 6000 of them and
they have a sunset provision that says
they can ramp it up in just a few years
so it's a terrible deal and like he said
it's there's still going to be a deal on
the table potentially if they make a
smart decision yeah you know and what
people Chuck Schumer says this was a
mistake but he was one of the people
against this deal yeah right right so I
mean a little hypocrisy there I think I
think you're talking politics I mean and
I but noticed that everybody who's
spoken says the president kept his
pledge and he said he's gonna do it and
he did it so if that's what this is
about well then I guess you can get your
super super super so you can keep going
right if it's about America well I don't
think it I think then you have to go
like sad sad sad sad very sick the
president yes because here's the thing
when the president spoke today he didn't
say oh yeah here's a major violation
that proves these people are not to be
trusted
no couldn't do that and guess what you
know why he couldn't do that it's
because people like Michael Hayden dan
coates the intelligence comedian coaches
his own guy have said we know of nothing
nothing within Iran's actions that would
constitute a violation of this deal
that's the same thing he was hearing
from his advisors before he got Bolton
and Pompeyo over at CIA so this is a
victory for Iran because it creates
distance between the United States and
our European allies secondly it
accelerates regional insecurity in the
Middle East it also hasn't going to have
an impact on global oil supplies we
don't know where that's gonna go could
drive up prices and then finally you
know the kid it's so funny in this
speech he says oh you know in seven
years Iran is going to be free under the
terms of this deal to create nuclear
weapons well guess what The Washington
Post checked that they gave them four
Pinocchios in other words no chance not
true but it doesn't seem to matter I
mean it you always say this is team
sport and if this is about team sport in
politics well I guess trunk people are
going to say great but if you care about
preventing Iran from getting a nuclear
weapon I think you have to say sad sad
sad awesome awesome awesome
super awesome awesome or awesome so
there's why because it's not about the
President fulfilling campaign promises
the reason why he made that decision and
came to that analysis because he studied
it and because he listened to smart
advisors so therefore he made that
pledge but you didn't do it in a
knee-jerk fashion as soon as he became
president he actually still continued to
listen to thoughtful deliberation on it
and then came to the conclusion he has
shown that he is somebody that's not
afraid to change his mind
when presented with persuasive factual
evidence to the contrary in this case he
determined that this was not a good deal
for the United States in fact it's a
billion-dollar push to help reach a
greater nuclear Iran that's why he
wanted to pull out of it why would we
subsidize a nuclear Iran and that's what
this was there was no a bite or teeth to
the inspections they were self
inspecting it's like Jessie looking in
the mirror in the morning and deciding
whether he looks awesome or not we're
complying yeah very similar analogy
thank you so much so so guys what's plan
what's the plan B that's what's
everybody's asking so what what exactly
North Korea is a good example well and I
also think that it's okay not to know
right one of the things the president
said at the end is that you're gonna
hear from Iran and they're gonna refuse
to deal and if I were in their shoes I
probably would too but you know I'll be
here when they want to talk and I think
eventually they have to come I think
that the Allies figure out a way to come
back
I mean unilateral sanctions are fairly
toothless and I do think one of ulnar
ability here is that you do put
sanctions on a country to change their
behavior if Iran had not actually done
anything to violate the deal as all of
these people had said then there might
be a problem there but the president was
also careful to do something else he
drops in the news in the middle of the
speech that secretary Pompeo has landed
in Pyongyang right and that they're
working on that deal as well there's
some critics that say well why would
North Korea want to enter into an
agreement with the United States if it
shows that it can't keep its word with
Iran I actually think it's well it's a
different word and I think that you also
are seeing some really impressive
coordination between the president's new
national security team of John Bolton
yes and secretary Pompeo and okay thank
you Gina Haspel who will have her
confirmation hearing tomorrow there's
they're all on the same page it might
not be the page that your opponents want
but there were a lot of opponents to
this Iran deal and it weren't it wasn't
just Republicans or conservatives I
would say with the North Koreans that
they would see that President Trump
doesn't want to make a deal for a sake
of the deal like John Kerry did who John
Kerry you know as a private citizen
discussing sanctions one with a foreign
power that could be a violation of the
Hatch Act also so yeah or the Logan I
can see you're familiar with this to
your point about them not violent if you
don't know because you can't get
inspections in there how do you know
they're not violating if you can't see
the military let me just say and then
just want to be you of course they want
to keep the deal we want enough de you
you want to know why because they get a
lot of energy natural gas and oil from
the Iranians and their corporations do
billions of dollars in trade deals with
the Iranian regime so it's in their best
interest
financially to keep those business deals
but you're not blowing is an American
company Boeing does business with Iran
so imagine with Boeing the boeing
response but it goes we know we got a
guy who pondered it goes beyond that
because guess what you keep talking
about Obama and the wings on his library
is that what this is about Jesse that's
what it's about and care I think we
could I think we can conclude that John
Kerry is no Dennis Rodman
[Laughter]